speaking of being anime princess like
ever since the first episode let first
time I was here uh I have been doing the
anime judge of crunch anime words so
still this year I just did my Paul I
mean we are still the round one process
of trying to do the nomination I just
did that last night oh damn nice oh for
this year's country roll Awards oh nice
for 2024 oh any spoilers allowed or but
every year is different every year their
voting system changes or judging system
changes and last year uh so last year
they made it clear that anything after
October is not going to be counted
because it's just too soon recy bias
yeah right now we're filming on October
is it 15th and yeah like just when we
started nominating like a full season
starts so it's still fresh in memory
when an actual voting start but it's
kind of unfair to start Jing yeah I
guess that's why the Oscars wait till
like
February the full year can be done
well I remember the previous crunch R
Awards there were some awards where like
a season had not even finished before
the judging process started just because
you have to start it a little bit early
but December in December the previous
the fall anime season still hasn't ended
yet yeah when you guys are co- streaming
CR manim award it actually happened like
you just guys him won and you guys
reaction was I too soon instead of like
yeah just SK like feel like it's too
soon cuz that was full anime maybe maybe
I'm controversial I just don't think
fans should be allowed to
vote I I think as fans and I'm speaking
as a fan myself we [__] suck at
voting like we we like most fans watch
maximum like less than 10 anime a year
and so it's it's kind of then unfair to
go through all of this judging process
where I mean because you watch a lot of
anime I feel like you you keep up with
everything uh and uh you go through this
careful process of of picking the
perfect nom ations and then everyone's
like well I I watched ju Ka this year so
I'm going to click all of that cuz
that's the biggest difference right is
that like judges are looking at these
shows in a much more critical lens right
because they know that that's coming up
whereas like the average ju kaen fan
isn't like looking at J kaon being like
well let's dissect as to why exactly is
the anime of the year like no this just
they [__] enjoying the show right so
obviously the the reason why they do fan
is because you get engagement on social
media website clicks all this kind of
and fans get involved I mean I I think
there is a good balance that could be
had because on the opposite side of
things now you have like the Oscars
which is the complete opposite of this
and it's better it's getting better it's
getting better but they since the Chris
Rock lap you know that's started coming
back that was the best content but I
feel every year they're also just
huffing more and more copi and being
like no no no we have to make it diverse
no more D no more diverse and it's like
all right just look just don't stop
thinking in The Meta game and just like
you know what you think was actually
good you CU cuz cuz when you have it to
like a closed group of Judges uh like
the Oscars is it kind of becomes just
politics in the end totally and it's you
know you literally have films being made
that's the entire marketing campaign
it's just let's appeal to the Oscars I
would argue the value of the Oscars is
because it's so prestigious because it
isn't a fan V if it was a fan vote it
would be like [__] Nickelodeon's kids
choices I mean I feel like the reason
why it became so prestigious cu well I
mean the history of it but because it's
so it's like you're appealing to certain
people and and you're kind of I don't
know there's a whole but I mean it's
getting less and less I guess important
what do you think about the game awards
then because that's like fan voted but
that's like a very very small percentage
which I think figed out they I feel like
the game awards has got a great balance
the game awards I don't think anyone
ever leaves the game awards thinking Man
X and X got robbed I think everyone I
think a lot of like people last year are
very happy with how it all turned out
you know um it is what it is and for the
nomination process I try to actually
pick names like I try to have a variety
just because it's a nomination process
it's not judging no it's not voting
process voting is going to be popularity
contest no matter what so I try to name
so many shows like for each category I
want to name like different shows uh
then n year the anim of the Year kind of
like got nominated for like so many
different categories and I was like h
well I couldn't help I got so I don't
know how many of you nomin like you did
the judging last year how many
nominations that you put down actually
came up as like the final nominations
obviously you can get some right you
know you can get some it's it's going to
make it you know for sure like oh like a
spy family or that this year probably
OKO is definitely nominated for a lot of
categories they deserve that actually
but like sometime it's about Marketing
in the west like I would so disappointed
that I couldn't see summertime render in
not even like animation
Disney Disney oh wow it hadn't been
noticed and yeah I I I think the the
problem is right now and because I've
been asked to be a crunch for judge
before and I just I just remember
thinking I don't like I don't know how I
come out of this with like being happy
you know
because because the problem the problem
is the problem is right now is that
there are just too much like anime even
for a judge to watch like like even even
I and I'm sure yourself we tried to
watch as much as possible but even so
there's probably some shows that people
have missed along the way like what do
you mean I can't nominate 50 isai shows
like this is
[__] actually I just want I just
want to nominate one at this point
that's that's all I want but who W won
best fantasy [__] Demon Slayer won
best fantasy last year I'm not even
joking which is so cap
I feel like if I was the producer and I
saw that I would be like guys hit me out
how about we [__] this thing I'll just
do I'll do a pro gam move and change
results like have different categories
each year and this year I thought it
went a little bit technical actually oh
lately or I think the understanding is
if they have a good sakuga like key art
it's like you know best animation right
usually you pick them for best animation
but this year they added not just best
animation but there is like a best art
Direction and best cinematography
and oh well how do we differentiate yeah
technical the average anime fan does not
know the difference they don't you know
you can't have like a best editing
category for fans cuz they don't [__]
pay attention [__] you know what I mean
like this is why in others things that's
you know you have that's not going to
make a difference they're still going to
vote [__] JS that's just that's just
two more awards for J Ka like so
hopefully we see like different names
for each category yeah hopefully you you
can you can fancy it up but if it's
still like a fan vote it's still always
going to be skewed towards the popular
vote which I think even like especially
now in the anime Community there has
never been such a bigger gap between
let's say Shonen and everything else you
know like the popularity Gap is like
insane right now especially with how big
like I I think one piece is getting
close to like mainstream now you know
it's getting close to that level of
popularity sure like it's it's kind of
like the same level as like you know
back when Marvel and comic book started
to get popular it was like Marvel and
then every Indie comic like it made
Marvel more popular but every Indie
comic scene everything Comics outside of
just the big two was just like unheard
of you know forgotten yeah for sure what
uh What shows have you enjoyed this year
then that you have nominated I actually
U I been I decided to binge watch One
Piece from beginning this year
wait what hold on I know he's taking
forever yeah no [__] it's like a
thousand
episodes yeah you know you start
watching like remember when w started
that was 25 years ago we were still
babies and you know we were still kids I
don't remember to go watching every sing
so I was like why do I start from the
beginning yeah but the first couple of
ARS are raw like it's it's hard to see
read the first 200 chapters was it was
tough it was slow so I can't imagine
watching and I'm caught up on manga so
some part I can kind of skim through
like you know what's coming already and
it does get better animation wise like
from the end of hake irland and wuni
like the animation upgrade was insane
fantastic but that's like 700 uh they're
they're going to remake the anime one
they're going to do the hunter hunter
treatment on it SK yeah because they'll
be like guys we can make free
money one piece two that's when is out
twoie when twoie com out exact same
thing but we cut out all the boring [__]
and make it cleaner yeah cuz I me so
you've watched one piece and you've had
time to watch other anime this year I'm
impressed with the amount of because I
remember the first time you came on the
podcast you specifically said this thing
to me and I didn't understand what you
meant at the time cuz I didn't know you
well enough but you were like man I just
a lot of people like they say they like
anime and video games but they don't
really like that I didn't know because I
didn't know you then I didn't realize
what you meant but I was like oh after
spending more time with you and and and
like getting to know you more I realized
oh oh doesn't [__] around with I I watch
ship like oh my God this just [__] like
I just wasted some time of course I
don't I don't know how you do you spent
all your time doing all this stuff but
you're also super productive it seems
because you're always posting stuff and
doing stuff but you then you'll be like
I just played every single Yakuza game
and and what I tried 100% one game and
I'm still regretting it I still want to
do it it's
91% yeah that's going to it's going to
take you an extra 100 hours to get that
9 put like more than 200 hours you also
sleep either like 1 hour or like 15
hours a day right I can never tell yeah
I love sleeping like I can just sleep
for more than 10 hours like a pregnant
lady like I can do that all day every
day well well I don't really go out so
yeah I watch anime when I eat you
know yeah yeah well what have what have
you been watching that you've enjoyed
then oh yeah also oh again another watch
but I've been trying to get into like a
power engine also toy do you remember
the toy version I mean nobody remembers
nobody was born but back then about toy
version of Spider-Man yes CPS of that I
really enjoyed watching it's like super
Sentai but like SPID that's like a
beginning of Super Sentai wait so not
only do you have enough time to rewatch
one piece watch all these new shows but
now you're watching to satu [__] as well
like how I know it's so hard to keep up
yeah I bet sometimes we cuz like we'll
get do the video shoots and I'll be like
we're going to meet up at 8 and Cal
would turn up like dead like I had two
hours I'm like what like yeah I I don't
know I was playing
games God I wish I could still live that
life yeah right yeah I dermatologist
more
often SK cleared up the skin can't get
old if you don't leave the house and
never go in the sun that is true by the
way your skin looks great today thank
you I've been moisturizing more often
Dam
told me you have a skare routine now
well I just moisturize which apparently
is well that's a skare routin helps yeah
apparently uh I didn't know this you
should just wear sunscreen every day
yeah did you know this I did not know
that I'm white so first of all it
matters more well because like isn't it
like on cloudy days or overcast days the
UV is actually stronger than on a sunny
day you just need to look at the app UV
that day and if it's like over like a
three although why do you think all
these like you know older women wearing
those like sleeve things like I
mean I I have no shame I just I in the
summer yeah cuz it's I I get cooked and
I I burn so I was like man I should
probably start moisturizing cuz I
already look like 50 and I
should I should probably start taking
care of myself I started doing the the
Mudan Strat as well I'm taking vitamins
you doing the vitamins now I want to see
if they he influenc you he influenced me
I want to see if they work my our editor
mood takes 27 pills in like one 27 what
something ridiculous it's like 12 it's
way too many wow very fair so I guess
makes sense you didn't do the health
exam before I didn't I'm checking an all
in one cuz I figured ah why not I'm
let's get them all so uh we'll see if it
helps I'll I'll update you guys in a few
months nice this is like the future
you're just like you're just eating
pills at the end yeah trying to trying
to be healthy but it's it's so hard yeah
when you're [__] sit at your desk all
day and then and then if not I'm
traveling and then when I'm traveling I
eat really badly drink a lot and all
that kind of [__] yeah is like let's go
and do a giant eating
challenge it's just visually nice it is
visually is visually impressive for sure
I think I'm think I'm done with the
eating challenge of I think just after
doing one I don't know my my mind is not
as strong as my stomach is a lot of the
times and seeing you guys do it I like
it knocks me out for just two days it's
like it's like you're eating like 3
4,000 calories yeah you got you done the
most eating challenges I guess yeah like
Chris and I have done what four now I
disgusting yeah that one was [__] I I
did one with Connor the spiciest Ramen
one that was at least kind of nice yeah
I mean I tasted good I was in so much
pain afterwards like i' I've I've I
figured it out now I've I told Chris
this and I'm like we we're going to keep
doing these like eating challenges just
cuz there's so many of them in Japan but
we're doing it once a year because any
more than that I am going to die at
40 it's just not healthy at all and
sometimes you know what it's not worth
the views sorry nicat avocado I don't
understand your mentality around that
but I just can't do it does they affect
your Bor system or it's just it's just
like I don't know you you finished the
meal and even if yeah even if the meal
was like kind of delicious like at the
beginning or whatever like just by the
end of it you just want to
die and I'm just like I know yeah and I
was like I know this one meal has just
aged me 5 years you know and I just
don't have the mentality to be like yeah
let's keep doing this you know to get
the clicks so yeah next next one will be
next year with something I don't know
I've noticed you've been streaming often
as well oh yeah I've been doing it for
fun but just yeah it's fun really it's
for fun I don't really consider myself a
streamer sometime I just tell people I'm
streamer you know just you know same
here you know it's just like depending
on the yeah at least at least you fully
committed to it now you fully have like
transferred over I I got hours I got a
clock in and out I got to do I got to
stream x amount of hours every month oh
so I guess it's full-time I just set
myself up to a full-time job wow fa on
top of everything else you're doing yeah
yeah so fun fine that's fine though it's
nice